welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka the guy who'd love to
have his helmet polished by madame gaza
and this video we're going to be
breaking down book of boba fett episode
3. the entry is filled with easter eggs
sorry about that brand new characters
and a whole host of things that hint
towards what's going to be happening in
the future i'm very immature and i
apologize now if that intro hasn't
ruined your light yet then come with us
to a galaxy far far away as we break it
all down in our spoiler filled video
make sure you smash the thumbs up button
if you love no fin more than our
lukewarm puns and also subscribe because
we saw be winging new breakdowns on the
show every week without the way thank
you for clicking this now let's get into
the book of bob affair episode 3. okay
so last week was very much a lawrence of
arabia s entry that showed boba fett's
rise in the desert clearly taking
inspiration from the likes of june he
helped the sam people to gain control of
their land once more we saw a completely
different side to them and whereas in
the past they've been simply regarded as
savages both this and the mandalorian
have showed that they possess more depth
also if someone could hook me up with
one of those lizards it'd be really
appreciated now in the present we also
saw his bow became face to face with two
twin huts who had black chrysanthemum
amongst their ranks that should have you
fully caught up as we dive into the new
episode which is called the streets of
mos esper in the entry we learn that
fett isn't really respected and thus he
works his way up from using gangs in the
streets so that he can take on the
elites kurt to the cavernous rocks
outside of jabba's palace and we see the
beaumont order which is a spider-like
droid that could be spotted in the
background of return of the jedi these
originally were a group known as the
beaumont monks who believe that in order
to achieve enlightenment that they had
to transform themselves into something
that would completely isolate their
minds they had their brains put into
jaws and these spider-like droids moved
them around now inside we see 8080
laying out a holographic map of most
esper this is actually being illuminated
by a droid much in the same way that
r2d2 showed luke a hologram of layer in
a new hope it's littered with red
markers and we learned that these are
businesses that were under the
protection of he who should not be named
no not voldemort
jabber now 8080 doesn't want to bring
him up in case fett feels insulted but
it very much shows how jabba's
reputation still goes on long after his
death this is hammered home by 8080
referring to the rescue by luke as the
sail barge disaster this makes it sound
like it crashed rather than what really
happened which is that lucanco defeated
the gangster when rescuing han solo i
think this line of dialogue has been put
in place to show how much fake news the
huts probably spread as if it got out
that one of them had been beaten by
rebels it might make others rise up
against them we learned that after this
there was a big power vacuum and as we
know bib fortuna stepped into jebus
place the rest of mos espo was then
divided up amongst the three families
which gives this intro somewhat of a
godfather slash mafia-esque feel to it
the trans oceans took the city center
and you might have noticed that whenever
fett and fennek go into town there's
often been shots of them sitting in the
area we learned the aqualish took the
workers district and they're the same
species as pandababa who appeared in a
new hope lastly the platoonians took the
starport and upper sprawl which we do
see at the end of the episode we learn
that bib lined the pockets of the mayor
and this is also why phet was expected
to give him a tribute in episode one at
this point one of the vassals arrives
and fett says that they might finally
learn what's going on in this murky fan
murky fan is a song by slab dragger
though i don't know if that's just a
coincidence as the lyrics of it don't
really have any meaning but it is a
banger to be fair now at this point we
meet lotha peel played by steven root
who you might recognize from get out and
also office space he's a water monger
from the workers district and moisture
is extremely scarce in the desert which
is why people have to do jobs like being
moisture farmers and also this in the
comics jabba actually put attacks on
water but we'll talk about that more in
the black chrysanthemum part of the
video now the manga mentions that
tatooine was once covered in oceans and
this actually ties into the origin story
that the planet had in the expanded lore
the whole of tatooine was filled with
luscious vegetation but over time it
eroded into the wasteland we see today
peel talks about a cyborg gang and how
their half man half machine something
that darth vader was also referred to as
they've modified their bodies with droid
parts to become even more deadly and
though peel one's fit to get rid of them
he sees how much fear they put into
their locals which is something that he
currently doesn't do he heads into
mozesper and at this point we're
introduced to the gang who may or may
not be led by odd lin i know that selfie
thatcher is playing here and i went
through the credits about four times
looking for what actress it could be but
it only says cyborg gang leader however
on the off chance it is lynn i thought
i'd quickly break her down in case you
don't know the character now arden first
debuted in the star wars game masters of
terrace cassie which was released back
in the day when uncle kevin spoilers was
on the playground ruining the phantom
menace on an unrelated subject yeah i
had a mate at school called annie
jackson and i told him yeah i told him
that palpatine was darth sidious but he
just wouldn't accept it we ended up in
different schools by the time that
revenge of the sith came out and i just
want to let the lad know that i haven't
forgotten i'll never forget anyway in
the original canon she and her boyfriend
zendor were both part of a faction of
jedi that split up from the main sect
this happened thousands of years ago and
they started delving into the darker
side of the force and though they
weren't classed as sith they very much
helped to lay the groundwork for them
arden was put in stasis and then
awakened by inquisitors that worked for
the emperor in the wake of his death at
the end of return of the jedi
interestingly in the expanded lore she
was actually killed by a clone of darth
sidious and whilst all this was written
before the rise of skywalker it'll be
interesting to see if that's
incorporated into this new story or not
personally i think that she's going to
be used to bring teres cassie more into
the mainstream canon after it was first
mentioned in solo a star wars story now
it does look like things are a bit
different and we see one of the gang
members has a cybernetic eye much in the
same way that silo 4 did in the comics
there's some really well-dressed people
amongst them and you kind of get the
feeling that they've been doing crime
for a long time to build up to this
point now it turns out the manga was
ripping them off and fed quickly settles
the score between them he says if you
don't like it you can move to mouse icy
which clearly still is the biggest hive
of scum and villainy in the galaxy fett
travels to there later on in the episode
and we learn that it's a hangout for the
pike clan who of course had the train
last week could do the title sequence
before we jump to a wart outside jabba's
palace that snags a one brad and a bird
at the same time that's a two for wanna
and this moment is very similar to when
we saw a war doing the same thing in
return of the jedi and it's sort of like
poetry they rhyme it also popped about
the sun last week at the tuscan camp and
i like that they keep bringing this
animal back now we catch fed back in the
back to tank recounting some of his old
memories including kamino when he
watched his dad pop out for a pack of
smokes on slave 1. the vision was also
seen during the tree scene last week and
it's clear he had a very lonely
childhood the clones of course all had
their quote-unquote brothers which meant
that they could at least form bonds but
vet's childhood seemed to be just him
spent in this room probably making
youtube videos because he had no life
now this loneliness is somewhat mirrored
in the rancor that we meet later on and
it shows that the pair do have some
common ground that they can bond over
kamino was also destroyed at the end of
the bad batch and it's sad that he can
never really return there and that his
childhood home is gone next we jump to
fat riding on top of a panther which is
a sign that one is high up within the
tuscan society typically the one on top
tends to lead and the others walk behind
so it shows he's been fully accepted by
them you also see the massive and the
kid who beat him watching on as he heads
out into the tunes he comes across some
jawas and shout out simon a bearman for
pointing out that we see stormtrooper
helmets being placed onto spikes which i
believe are the same ones that mano came
across in the gunslinger episode we also
see pelimoto who too appeared in that
entry along with her pitroids her
appearance is short and sweet but it
ties the entire universe together and i
love that all the paths kind of
intersect at this moment the divide of
the stormtrooper helmets also shows the
power divide that is symbolic of
tatooine fete rides high in a band there
and eventually he will control a large
part of the planet whereas pele walks
along the ground because she's just a
normal person trying to get by vette
meets with the pike syndicate and their
leader mentions zabadaya which is their
homeworld this planet was located at the
end of the kessel run and it's one of
their strongholds they refused to pay
protection to more than one party since
they already give tribute to the kington
striders who are the speeder bike gang
that that came face to face with toshi
station fett says that they won't hear
from the nikdo san riders again and he
returns to his people to kinda eat his
words now during his ride we can see the
most size of the skyline which contains
monuments that are similar to the
japanese architecture that was
referenced in the asuka tano mandalorian
episode smoke rises in the sky though
and vet returns to find the tuscan home
looking like what happens when anakin
takes a visit to meet some of the kids
everyone has been slaughtered and the
crest of the neat toes has been left
behind we saw this being spray painted
in episode 1 and it looked like me when
i was 14 and used to spray paint dick
onto walls now that burns the bodies
which is somewhat of a tuscan tradition
that also mirrors the way that the
jedi's do the same thing he leaves his
weapons behind and it's a very summer
moment that feels like a real gut punch
now the piece is quickly broken by the
arrival of black cressentine who shows
up like a nightmare to kill him whilst
he sleeps fat gets thrown against his
jetpack and we also see that there are
whistling birds on his wrist armor which
were weapons that mano got in his series
now as for black chrysanthemum we've
already done a full video breaking down
the character but if you want a quick
history on him then this is the video
for you you're some of a [ __ ] now black
chrysanthemum first appeared in darth
vader issue 1 and we learned that the
wookie fled kashyyyk after becoming an
outcast after the events of revenge of
the sith the empire ended up taking over
the planet and they enslaved the
population black case set up a trap for
slavers and trend oceans arrived on the
planet to capture wookies in order to
sell them or their pulse chrysanthemum
killed all but one and then forced him
to take him to the zanti brothers where
he volunteered as a gladiator the zonti
brothers ended up enslaving him though
and they injected metal into his hands
so that he had permanent knuckle dusters
chrysanthemum ends up electrifying
spiked ones on the outside of his hand
in this episode so it's difficult to
tell whether this original part of him
is canon or not however in the comics he
actually punched c-3po and got
electrocuted because of his hands so
potentially he now uses external knuckle
dusters so that doesn't happen again now
after he was sold by the zanti brothers
chrysanthemum vowed to do to them what
they had done to him and eventually he
earned his freedom and started working
as a bounty hunter chrysanthemum first
debuted alongside barbara fett and
though we can't say for definite whether
disney are keeping all that cannon or
not he's referred to as a gladiator by
fed so the two have clearly met before
now over the years chrysanthemum worked
under jabba the hutt and he even ended
up fighting obi-wan after he put an end
to jabba's war attacks chrysanthemum
kidnapped owen laws aka luke's uncle and
the young skywalker even showed up in
the issue i think this would make an
awesome episode in his upcoming disney
plus show and if you want to read the
full fight then make sure you check out
star wars issue 20. chrysanthe lost the
battle and ended up leaving tatooine
disgraced and though he did go back to
working for jabba his reputation took a
lot to save chrysanthen also worked
alongside dr aphra for a big part of the
comics and he even saved her life after
she was jettisoned into space by darth
vader i'd love to see her show up in the
series at some point as she's one of the
best characters from the expanded lore
that has worked both for and against the
empire i believe that when we last saw
him that they were working together so
it's going to be interesting to see how
he ended up in the employ of the hutts
now chrysanthemum has fed beaten pretty
badly but he uses his gaffy stick which
he made with the duskins to even the
odds however he's not really much of a
match but luckily the gang show up to
save the day realizing that the
strongest protection that fed has is the
gomorians he goes for them first but
this is why you should always carry a
gun bk you could have just shot the lad
and been gone anyway croissant is sealed
in the ranco pit and he's dropped
through a trap door which is the same
one that the dancer fell through in
return of the jedi kurta the big banquet
table and we see a frog like creature
that's appeared in the saga as well as
some calamari what's that it's a wrap
now fett needs to respond to the attempt
on his life by the twins and speak of
the devil they arrive on their litter
recur to jabba's gate and i love how the
opening of this looks like giant teeth
it very much gives the appearance that
jabba's palace is the belly of the beast
and it's such a cool image now i also
feel really bad for that little mouse
being used as a towel and you can see
that he's living in hell however the
huts aren't that bad as they've come to
apologize so hey maybe they've changed
now with them they bring a rancor along
with danny trejo we discover that rancor
is actually imprint on the first person
they see and because of this this one's
eyes have been covered knowing this it
actually makes sense as to why the guy
in return of the jedi was so upset when
the rancor died because it likely saw
him as a parent we learned that they're
emotionally complex creatures and that
they even suffer from depression they're
quite peaceful and less threatened and
i'd love to see that riding on top of
one at some point in the series which he
says he'd like to do now it's mentioned
that the witches of dathomir even rode
on them at one point and this could be
referring to the night's sisters which
are characters that you might know from
the clone wars now in the bad batch we
did come across a rancor child called
muchi who it was believed would be in
this series but he already had his eyes
open so i don't think they're one in the
same and the hurts mention that the
territory was promised to another
syndicate which i'm guessing is the
pikes as they probably were also tied in
with the tuscan deaths they show up at
the end of the episode and want to lay
claim to the planet and i can see them
becoming the big bads because they maybe
maybe their huts have changed maybe
they've changed now you know things are
pretty bad if the huts are so scared
that they have to leave and though it
could be the pikes deep down i hope that
it's actually watto now chrysanthemum is
brought out and it's recommended that he
gets sold back to the gladiators which
is a nod to the zanti brothers they say
tatooine is a worthless rock and that
fetch should just leave but he wishes to
stay behind and basically do it dune
paul also had the opportunity to leave
arrakis but instead he stayed there in
an attempt to turn it into a kingdom
that frees bk and we did theorize last
week that he might even end up joining
forces with him at some point which i
definitely think is set up in this
moment treyarch introduces fed to the
rancor and the latter talks about
feeding it toronto which is an animal
that we saw cgi'd into a new hope the
blinders are taken off and the beast
imprints onto fett forming a bond
together 8080 pops his head around like
his secretary and says that the mayor is
fully booked but fett isn't gonna wait
for an appointment they head into town
with a bike gang from back to the future
too and it all ramps up for the climax
of the episode the front door staff are
still there led by david pasquezi and
doesn't this do just like have monday
morning energy this guy was pretty much
my entire mood when i worked 9-5 and
yeah he's just fed up now the door is
locked but fennec ends up cracking it
open in star wars you see destroying a
door panel control can either open the
door or close it and lock it just
depends on what you need for this
situation now inside we can see the map
has bolted and fenix says the curse word
dank ferric which has also popped up in
the mandalorian a number of times davey
boy flees and his ride looks like the
same model as the one that han wrote in
at the start of solo a star wars story
he doesn't care about the astromech
protocol or pitroids and we can catch a
banter there too we can also see what i
believe is r5d4 who you might know as
being the droid whose motivator bust up
during a new hope the chase is a pretty
cool way to end the episode and we see
his water is splashed in the street
showing that this guy doesn't give an f
the cyborgs use their enhancements to
help destroy the ride and one of them
flies through a painting in the street
now if you take a freeze frame of it you
can see that it has salacious chrome in
it
bib fortuna and also fett on the right
i'm kind of thinking that this has been
purposely done as a way to keep the
legend of jabber alive whilst also
showing that fett was somewhat just a
servant to him another person that the
people should respect it's really
demeaning and it shows just how far the
locals are going in their disrespect the
person crashing through it however shows
that this image is false and it very
much symbolizes that fet is here to stay
now you also see a droida showing 2-bit
along and you might remember that anakin
and padme had one of these carry them on
tatooine in attack of the clones he's
running off the road and we learned that
the mayor is working with the pikes we
see a transport come in with them on
board and they arrive like an army this
arrival is very similar to a moment in
attack of the clones when the army show
up at the end and yeah it's sort of like
poetry we keep doing that craft joke now
there's also a moment there could be a
nod to the matrix in which one of the
gang members checks them out in his
rearview mirror before he writes off
much like how trinity did in that film
afternoo was captured by agent smith now
we learned that these are just the first
wave and they bring war with them though
the pikes are set up as the big bad i
could actually see it being kira behind
it who would have taken over the reigns
from darth maul after he was killed by
obi-wan later on in the timeline i'd
love to see her back and it would just
be way cooler than these guys now kira
could also lead to other people showing
up in the series and if you want to know
who that could be then check out our
ending of episode 2 video where we talk
about some of the leaks anyway that
wraps up the episode and i can't wait to
see what happens next week now as for my
thoughts on the episode this was another
really great one and i think the series
has been super solid so far super solid
yeah i said i used that term now
whenever a new disney plus show ends up
releasing there's often a lot of
division over it whereas i can see the
criticism being valid in a lot of the
mcu shows i think this series is really
well done on a number of levels to the
point i personally can't find much
default with it i think there's just a
lot of dislike for star wars in general
and if you don't like the show at this
point i don't think it's really gonna do
anything to turn you around because this
is what it is now the main criticism
i've seen is that boba fett has been
taken from being one of the most badass
characters in the galaxy as someone
who's trying to do deals and go on
vision quests but to me that's what they
needed to do like it or not the original
burba was a very two-dimensional
character and he was more of a cool suit
that was used as a plot device rather
than being an actual character i think
this show has taken him from being that
to a three-dimensional one that has
depth learns things and also questions
his own actions this is kind of what you
need in a show and if you compare the
character depth of the mandalorian
season one to how din jaron was in two
you can see the evolution is indeed
needed now i really like the show and
they just keep giving me more of what i
like so i keep liking it do you see what
i'm saying yeah you kind of get where
this review is heading now i know my
opinion isn't the be all and end all
even though i sometimes act like it is
so if you don't like it or if you do
let's open up what you're enjoying and
not enjoying in the comments section
below if you do you'll be entered into a
competition on the 30th of january in
which you're giving away three copies of
an mcu boxer of your choice all you have
to do to be on the chance of winning is
make sure you like the video subscribe
with notifications on and just drop a
comment with your thoughts in general
now we pick these comments at random at
the end of the month and the winners of
the last one are on screen right now so
if that's you then message me on twitter
at heavy spoilers if you want something
else to watch then make sure you check
out our full breakdown of black
chrysanthe which will be linked on
screen right now we went over the full
characters back story and also gave our
theories for what could be happening
down the line so definitely head over
there right after this if not thanks for
sitting through this video hope you
enjoy the rest of your week take care
yourself peace